ونتابع ايضا في نفس الموضوع ضمن هذه
التغطيه ينضم الينا من بيروت العميد الياس
حنا الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
سيد الياس
يعني كثير من النقاط التفصيليه التي يفترض
السؤال عنها لكن لنبدا بالمجمل كيف قرات
هذا الحدث
هذا اليوم بسقوط صاروخين في بولندا
حسن منذ بدء الحرب روسيه تهدد ان اي سلاح
يدخل الى اوكرانيا من اي منطقه هو هدف
مشروع اليوم نحن في مرحله جديده مهما كانت
سيناريو اذا كانت الصواريخ اوكرانيه تربح
روسيه هي ون ست ويشن لان الملامه ستقع على
الاوكرانيين واذا كانت روسيه مع القدره
على النكران هي رساله ليست كافيه هي رساله
كافيه كي يصل التحذير لاوكرانيا لاوكرانيا
بل نيته وامريكا ولكنها ليست كبيره وخطيره
جدا كي تذهب لتفعيل بنود اتفاقيات همم
النيته اليوم هل يتم الحديث عن خرسان نحن
في مرحله تخطيناها وهو كما يقال انه
المصيبه تنساها اذا اتت مصيبه اكبر ذهبنا
الى مسرح مختلف الى واقع مختلف تماما
تماما همم حسن همم كانك تشير الى مجموعه
من الاهداف الروسيه من وراء ذلك وكانك
عمليا همم ترجح ان تكون هذه الصواريخ همم
روسيه باي هدف تحديدا
اولا هي رساله لحلف الناتو كما قلت هي
تحذير ورساله كي تصل الرساله سريعا في
ظروف معينه يعني تاتي خرسان اجتماع
ويليامبرز مع نظيره الروسي في تركيا ويبدو
ان الموضوع مختلف لم يتم الاتفاق على شيء
معين اتت من ضمن حمله شامله وكامله 100
صاروخ على كل اوكرانيا واتت هذه الحادثه
هي لم تاتي منفرده كي يتم التركيز عليها
فقط اليوم المطلوب هو رساله لكل حلف ان هو
خاصه
لانه من البولندا هي الهضم كما يقال هي
مركز الثقل لكل شيء يدخل الى همم اوكرانيا
ولا يجب ان ننسى حسن ان همم لبولندا مع
اقليم كلينغراد ما يقارب ال 220 230 كلم
وهو اقليم روسي يعني الموضوع هو التركيز
الاساسي او مركز الثقل الاساسي هو على
المرحله القادمه هي مرحله جديده
طيب سؤال المرحله جديده هل هل الواقع
العسكري الروسي في اوكرانيا اليوم
يسمح لها بالهروب الى الامام اكثر وتوجيه
رسائل بهذه الخطوره الى الولايات المتحده
الى نيته واا توسيع دائره الصراع
هي لان الانجاز العسكري همم تخلل ثلاثه
انسحابات من اكياس من اركاب واخيرا من
خرسان لان هذا الفشل العسكري بانتظار
مرحله الشتاء التحضير
والضغط البشري والانسان على اوكرانيا من
تدفئه من همم كهرباء ومن مياه وهو هذا
الاساس هي رساله لمن يدعم اذا صح التعبير
اوكرانيا للمرحله القادمه ليوم المرحله
الجديده على الساحه الاوكرانيه هناك تصعيد
كبير جدا على جبهه اركان على جبهه جمباز
والهدف منها التحقيق شيء يوازي ما خسرته
في خرسان تاتي هذا الموضوع وكاننا لا
نتحدث ابدا عن خرسان هي رساله ايضا للداخل
الروسي بعض الانتقادات الكثيره خاصه من
همم
الذي يعني فتح بشكل هجوم شامل وكامل على
الرئيس بوتين دون ان يسميه
هي بتفهم اذا ان في الروس السريع همم ان
تكون قد استهدفت هولندا
القدره ا ا ا النفي من الطبيعي دائما يعني
هناك حديث مزدوج لدى روسيا بما يحصل داخل
اوكرانيا وحتى بما يحصل في الخارج القدره
على النكران اذا تحدثنا كما تحدثت
المراسله من موسكو ان صواريخ هي من لفيف
300 تتمتع تملك همم اوكرانيا صواريخ اسفل
اسماء يعني انت اذا ذهبت الى مسرح الجريمه
او مسرح القصف وبدات بحثا جديه قد لا تجد
شيء يميز السلاح الروسي عن السلاح
الاوكراني ولكن انا اعتقد هناك معلومات
كافيه فيها لنعرف من اين اتت من الصواريخ
من الاقمار الاصطناعيه من الرادارات وما
شبه يمكن رصدها همم حسن
هل هل يمكن معرفه مصدر هذه الصواريخ في
لحظتها انها تحتاج الى وقت
يمكن ان تعرف المصدر ولكن يستلزم التحقيق
لظروف معينه يعني هناك تحقيق ميداني على
الارض لمعرفه الانفجار سبب الانفجار ما هو
السلاح المستعمل في هذا الوقت تحدثنا عن
رفع مستوى الجوزيه العسكريه في بولندا
وهذا امر طبيعي لانه دائما يخطط للسناري
السيء لا يعرف احد ماذا حصل انطلاقا من
هذا المبدا فاذا يمكن معرفه مصدر الصواريخ
ممكن من الاقمار الاصطناعيه ممكن من
الادارات حتى على مستوى ذخيره المدفعيه او
قذيفه مدفعيه هناك ما يسمى بالكونتر
باتريا التي تعرف مصدر القذيفه لتعود
فترمي عليها انا اعتقد انه ممكن ان هذه
الامور ولكن حتى لو نكرت روسيه لا يمكن
معاقبه روسيه لماذا لانها رساله ترسل
التحذير ولكنها لا تجعل
الحلف النهايه ان يفعل البند الخامس وحتى
البند الرابع هو طبيعي البند الرابع
هذه النظريه
هناك نظريه اخرى تقول همم اذا اخذناها
بعين الاعتبار وهي نظريه روسيه مثلا انها
صواريخ اوكرانيه هدفها مزيد من الضغط على
نيته وعلى الدول الاوروبيه من اجل مزيد من
الدعم ومن اجل وقت الحديث عن التفاوض وهي
رساله للولايات المتحده لوقف الحديث عن
التفوق
هذه نظريه ولكن البلوزه بيليتي يعني
القدره او دراستها بالعمق حسن لا يمكن
بالمطلق ان تكون صحيحه لماذا لانه لا يمكن
ان تجر اوكرانيا حلف الناتو الى حرب
عالميه ثالثه نوويه وهذا تعرفه اوكرانيا
رحم الله امر ينعدم فحده فوقف عنده لا
اعتقد اليوم انه اوكرانيا تغامر بهذه
الحسابات الخاطئه كي تحرم من كل شيء على
المدى البعيد لانه الامريكي لا يزيل يقول
لا يكون لن يكون هناك
سلام او وقف للنار بدون ان تكون اوكرانيا
مساهمه اوكراني حققت ما حققت بسبب الدعم
الغربي وخاصه الامريكي ولكن لا يمكن اذا
ان تلعب هذه اللعبه الخطيره جدا جدا اللهم
اذا كان هناك خطا معين خطا ثقني او خطا
بشري اوكراني ماذا عن بولندا هنا
هولندا بولندا اذا صح التعبير هي مركز
الثقل الاوروبي اليوم اليوم في مواجهه
روسيه لديها صواريخ باتريوت لديها
بطاريتين تطلب ثلاثه لديها ما يقارب ال
10,000 جندي امريكي موجود هذا يعتبر
بالمعنى الحمايه ولديها جيش متقدم لنعترف
بهذا الامر المرحله الحاليه هي مرحله
الاستنفار وهذا امر طبيعي يعني الاستغفار
لا يعني الذهاب الى حرب الاستغفار امر
طبيعي لمعرفه ماذا يحدث وبالتالي همم
الذهاب الى اليه الصعود والتصعيد خاصه
البند الرابع الذي يقول بعمليه استشاريه
يعني اليوم لا يمكن لها ان تذهب الى حرب
منفرده لانها قد تجر
حلف النيته او او كانها تفعل البند الخامس
غصبا عن اراده القوى الكبرى خاصه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه البند الرابع هو
استشاري لمعرفه هل فعلا هذا الامر يهدد
الخطر الكبير على نيته
شبه لتفعيل الماده الخامسه وهذا امر كبير
جدا جدا تفعيل الماده الخامسه ولكن
اوكرانيا هي مركز الثقل والضغط في الحرب
الاوكرانيه منذ البدء وحتى الان وممكن في
المستقبل هل يمكن لي اوكرانيا عفوا
لبولندا ان تبتلع الصاروخين
طبيعي حسن يعني اليوم نتحدث عن هولندا لا
يمكن لها ان تذهب الى حرب منفرده ولا يمكن
لها ان تبقى بدون الدعم الامريكي والدعم
الناتو النيتو اليوم هو الذي يمتد مستقبلا
من فنلندا من فنلندا وحتى تركيا هو الدرع
الواقي لهذه الدول او ما يسمى بالامن من
ضمن الجماعه او اا يعني مثل الامن ضمن
القطيع اذا صح التعبير الحلف انه هو جزء
اساسي هو الراجع الاساسي ل روسيه وان
لماذا تقوم روسيا بهذا الامر وتخافي موضوع
نيته لانه اقترب من الحدود الاساسيه
لروسيه او المنطقه الاساسيه التاريخيه لمن
المحيط المباشر ما الذي يمنع روسيا من
توجيه الرسائل مشابهه الى دول اخرى في
الناتو وبنفس الصيغه وبنفس السياق ما
دامتيا مطمئنه الى ان الى ان تفعيل الماده
الخامسه متبعد
صح موضوع اساسي اليوم يجب ان ننتظر لمعرفه
من هو مسبب هذه الحادثه وكيف سيكون الرد
الامريكي او الرده ليكون بطريقه مباشره
نرفع مستوى الردع يعني اليوم حسن هذه
الصواريخ اذا كانت روسيه شيء واذا كانت
اكرانيا شيء ولسيه كما قلت مستفيده اذا
كانت فعلا روسيه هي ترفع مستوى التحدي
ومستوى الرابع الى المستوى الاعلى فاذن
يجب ان يكون هناك رد من القوى الاخرى من
النيه ومن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رد
لاعاده رسم خارطه جديده او معادله جديده
لموضوع الردع وخاصه الموضوع النووي وتم
الحديث عنه في انقره او في في تركيا كما
قلت انا بيرز ونظيره الروسي همم منذ يومين
او ثلاثه هل يمكن ان تلجا همم دول النيته
الى رفع مستوى دعمها نوعيه
المعطى لاوكرانيا ردا على ذلك
ليس بالضروره حسن لانه هذه ما حصل ليس الى
درجه مت
قدمه درسنا ال- ال- تاثير السلاح الامريكي
والتكتيك المستعمل والجغرافي على الساحه
الاوكرانيه نرى ان الجيش الاوكراني حقق
تقريبا معجزه المرحله القادمه 400 مليون
دولار اخر مساعده تتناول فقط سلاح
الهايمرز كزخيره وتتناول ايضا اليات مدرعه
وتتناول تجهيزات لمرحله الشتاء القادمه
وهذا امر يعطي افضليه للجيش الاوكراني على
الجيش الروسي اليوم الصمود الاوكراني ان
كان في بخمود او ان كان في صفاته او
كريمينا وبالتالي تدعيم الانتصار في خرسان
هذا امر قد يؤدي الى مرحله جديده شكرا لك
الخبير العظيم والاستراتيجي حدثنا من
بيروت